each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
my great pleasure to have a nick we've
ER from Berkeley icsi Research Institute
Nick's Institute and as well as UCSD
research group have been working
together uncovering the underground
economy as well as a bunch of other
network security which has made really
significant impact so I'm really happy
that Nick is here with us and telling us
about two pieces of work so there are
two talks the first talk is about NAT
Eliza and he has some very exciting
story on some ice fees I will not you
know you are here all the exciting sorry
from Nick firsthand the next talk is
about the spam and underground economy
ok.thank unique thank you very much the
way I figured it if I'm flying up to
Microsoft I might as well give to talks
rather than one also it gave me an
excuse to prepare the second talk this
first one I've given in a couple of
places because metalizer is this big
Network measurement tool that we've
built it icsi um it has been widely
successful at this point as network
measurement tools go how many people
have run it before well if you haven't
you probably want to run it on your own
network just to find out what exactly is
broken if you have run it again because
we keep adding new tests also it's
really fun to run on random hot spots so
this is joint work with Christian Boris
Gregor and Vern um Boris while he was at
it see as a visitor and this work is
sponsored by the National Science
Foundation with additional support from
google and Comcast as well as ec2 time
from amazon and again opinions are
myself not of those of the sponsor
co-authors so let's start off with an
anecdote of how web search is supposed
to work for people well they type in
something into the browser's at our
search bar in this case it's internet
explorer 8 and the browser goes okay ask
the DNS resolver what's the address of
the sir
search engine which by default is being
i'm using this example not because I met
Microsoft because but because this is
what actually happens for more people
the result comes back the request goes
to the web server and the reply goes
however we saw something interesting for
about one to two percent of metalizer
sessions so not a huge number but enough
to be really significant and I will get
back to what this was later but as a
teaser the ISP had installed some sort
of DNS appliance in their network and
some third party for this purpose is
unknown was running a proxy server again
the user does a query the DNS resolver
returns the address of the local Akamai
node that's serving Bing and the
resolver appliance in between there the
appliance in between the resolver and
the user goes oh wait this is a request
for burnt Bing I'm going to change it to
the address of a proxy server the
request goes to the proxy server and in
this example nothing happens request
gets forwarded to Bing results come back
and well nothing happens the proxy
Ford's it on and the user has no
understanding of what happened this is
just one example of how the network
really works in practice for people and
it gets on to this lovely theoretical
view of the internet we have where we've
got our server over on that side and the
user on this side traffic goes back and
forth but in reality the path our
packets take might as well be napoleon's
march on moscow um we have fragments are
just not allowed by the network these
days um we have hidden proxies on
various networks for dns HTTP and other
protocols we have this problem called
buffer blow where the network can do
great file transfers or the network can
do interactive tasks but if you try to
do both at the same time you're in a
world of pain we have this
of NX domain wild carding anybody who
thinks that an error should be properly
reported back to the computer doing it
is unfortunately disagreeing with the
most of the ISPs out there and we have
this where ISPs were man-in-the-middle
in search sites for up until a month ago
completely unknown reasons and finally
this lovely gentleman created the home
gateway the home gateway our net is an
abomination unto god and man no
fragments broken dns resolvers ftp
proxies sip proxy if a nap can break the
network in a new and interesting way
there's at least one vendors whose nats
breaks the network in that particular
interesting way i think the way to put
it all naats are broken all naats are
broken differently so we wanted a tool
to know what the network actually is so
we wanted to rules an easy-to-use
network survey for anybody basically the
motto is so easy my mother can run it um
and indeed it is actually easy enough
that I can have my mother run this tool
as I she doesn't have to install the
applet it's two mouse clicks for the
typical user she's running a mac windows
XP has java installed windows by default
windows XP is still your biggest market
share so for all those users it's two
mouse clicks as well as a detailed
diagnostic tool for expert including
what we call up wheel we call mom mode
debugging tell your mother to run
metalizer have her send you the results
and now you know all the different ways
her network is broken and so we targeted
the web browser with just two mouse
clicks and we did it in java rather than
JavaScript because javascript doesn't
allow us to do rock traffic and we
didn't do it in flash because flash
Gabe's gives us headaches but there's a
lot of sneakiness in our tests and
I've just looked at it and there same
origin policy as weird one of the nice
things about Java is it has blamed the
user by passive same origin so our
architecture is a rather distributed we
built a cloud-based service so our
front-end web server dns server is
running a taxi all our servers are
custom we wrote them ourselves because
they fold spindle and mutilate protocols
in interesting ways then the test runs
on a ec2 note we right now tend to run 5
ec2 notes at a time but we've run as
many as 20 when we're expecting a flash
crowd and this probes the network for
everything and then a result page is
delivered and then we fetch the result
back and now I try to do the bold thing
of a live demo on the network so let's
get on the guest network this doesn't
count in the mouse clicks okay that was
at a hot spot and I would try to do a
search in the brown just as you
described and instead of actually
getting some hidden proxy what actually
happened was instead of getting a big
result I got a result from some other
search n 0 redirected that would hijack
me away from bing to another search
engine that's interesting we've
contemplating adding in a test for that
direct to our server because if it's
done using DNS metalizer would capture
it if it's done using direct injection
we don't currently capture it but we do
capture direct for a for rewriting which
a couple of ISPs are doing where the ISP
looks at the 404 page and rewrites it so
this is the basic user experience they
see our web page it's got a big start
analysis button although if we ask my
sister who's doing marketing stuff it's
not
big enough they click the start analysis
button it gets redirected to a random
back end node and there's a Java signed
applet dialogue that smells click number
two if they click deny most tests still
run just not all of them um and then it
starts running and the results display
after way too much and um the guest
network here is relatively clean there's
a little bit of port filtering namely
the windows ports yes even Microsoft is
unwilling to allow the windows ports
onto the internet and DNS passes through
a firewall that's protocol aware and
there are a couple of minor bugs in the
DNS server on basically it's not doing
failover for TCP right common annoying
um doesn't really matter until you want
to start doing DNS SEC and then when you
start doing DNS SEC this may be a
problem um so back to the talk yes it
works well enough that I'm willing to do
live demos in all my talks so to give
you an idea of the test suite um this is
actually most of the test suite we've
added in for a for rewriting detection
we've added in um some more DNS probing
we've added in upnp queries and it
really depends what the pc is how they
react to the paper the imc paper
committee loved our paper the sitcom
paper committee said this reads like a
data dump one thing we have is lots of
biases um metalizer is run by geeks far
more linux far more Firefox and you'd
ever expect in the real world far more
open dns than you'd expect in the real
world we have a tendency towards flash
crowds so our initial flash crowd was
biased towards comcast users we recently
received 20,000 visitors from Germany
because we
German or high Cyprian translation and a
link to on their page and as a result a
lot of German geeks go oh this is a
really cool tool um we've participated
in at least two ipv6 deployment tests
Tory Anderson's trial if users had
problems it threw up metalizer Comcast
ipv6 deployment trial arm and one online
game has decided through no knowledge of
our own that metalizer is a cool
debugging tool and this is a quote from
their faq none of this also work my
internet is pwned and the answer is run
metalizer post the results in the forum
and somebody who's a geek in the forum
will actually be able to find out what's
going wrong we didn't intend this but it
shows just how usable this is for mom
level debugging so one thing we do is we
really explore to exploit Java same
origin policy um if the signature is
rejected we are confined to same origin
and we wanted as many tests to run as
possible within that fortunately Java
same origin is actually amazingly
permissive from our point of view we can
contact our own origin server on any
port using raw TCP and UDP as well as
HTTP through the Java API um no
objections it allows us to do whatever
we want and since we have raw TCP and
UDP we can do anything that's network
layer and above we can play games with
protocols we can do direct DNS all sorts
we can perform any DNS lookup but the
Java VM enforces same word unit DNS sort
of if the answer is the origin servers
IP address that answer is returned
otherwise it raises a security exception
of this request would violate same
origin you aren't supposed to know about
any other IP addresses but this allows
us boolean property tests on the DNS
infrastructure you do a query
it either returns the server's IP
address or an error so as long as it's
something that's a boolean property with
the resolver itself we can test it
without violating same origin however if
the signature is accepted java San
boxing is gone java believes in a blame
the user sandbox there's one click to
bypass the sandbox and if the applet
does something wrong so for example how
is glue policy handled does uh the DNS
resolver accept arbitrary in Bailey with
glue records does it except in bailiwick
Lou records only when they're in the NS
RR set does the resolver validate DNS
SEC is one that we will be able to do
can the resolver fetch large responses
over TCP so for that one we send
truncate back with false if it caches
that it doesn't and then when it retries
with TCP we send the true value so this
allows a large number of tests to be
done almost everybody the user so that's
another clue yeah that's click to a long
denied click yes and um I hate to admit
it but there's basically you I bugs
involved that we are inadvertently but
happily exploiting the Java dialogue
actually is fairly reasonable for the
Mac it's not great but it says the
applet is requesting access to your
computer deny allow deny means run
within same origin we can't touch the
disk we can't touch the computer so it
could be much clearer but it's okay it's
it's great for our purposes it's kind of
ok from a user education standpoint sons
dialog box however for windows um what
does this mean this applications digital
signature cannot be verified
it can't be verified because I'm running
on debug so I'm running with a non
verified self signed certificate in this
case this is its dialogue if it has no
clue where the codes coming from run or
cancel do you know what cancel means run
with same origin run means run by
passing same origin this is a textbook
example of how not to design a dialog
box to educate users but it's great for
us because it means everybody bypasses
same origin so the first result of
interest is fragments and path MTU
discovery um we test fragments by
sending a 2000 by UDP Datagram so it
should be just fragmented by the network
it set the one sent from our server or
set without DF set so things should
refract meant etc 8% can't send
fragments 8% can't receive fragments so
basically fragmentation to the client
does not work on the modern Internet um
this is due to stateless firewalls and
Nats it's easy to make a stateless
firewall break all fragments people do
it all the time um those who can send
fragments may have an MTU whole three
percent of the sessions I just can send
a two thousand bite UDP data grant but
cannot send a 1,500 bite UDP Datagram
this is largely due to we'll get to it
in a bit PPP over Ethernet which is
still distressingly common that doesn't
exactly match would puts on the slide
you mean that three percent of sessions
can send 3 2000 by friends or three
percent of sessions which can send three
percent of the sessions which can send
fragments can't send a sub fragment
value that would be fragmented on
anything other than an ethernet network
so I hope that's precise and basically
they don't have a full 1500 bite
ethernet MTU and something keeps
fragments from working
our server Java does not allow us to
send raw packets our servers do so we
have a UDP echo server that reads and
writes raw UDP packets it can return the
size of the initial fragment received so
we can see what the fragment is i can
send packets with DF set and specific
size replies with ICMP 6 too big it
basically supports trace route
functionality from the server to the
client with path MTU discovery so we can
figure out where the path MTU bottleneck
is um and the network's mostly but not
all Ethernet there's this great quote I
don't know what the physical layer 20
years from now will look like but it
will be called Ethernet and have a 1,500
bite MTU well least right now but
there's a lot of PPP over Ethernet still
out there there's a lot of old dsl
modems and they're configured with pppoe
this is the denominator close what do
you mean this is for all our user base
of 300,000 plus sessions so this is a
good representative survey of the
internet modulo we would have hoped that
with the number of geeks involved this
would be lower because geeks are willing
to pay for better internet and upgrade
their modems so that's kind of
distressing in these cases where you
should get an ICMP too big sent only
sixty percent sent them so path MTU
discovery for ipv4 has been decreed
broken on the internet it doesn't work
on forty percent of the time you never
get the ICMP too big um and basically
path MTU discovery must use fall back
when ICMP isn't received oh and you guys
don't have this problem but we do linux
uses path MTU discovery on UDP by
default and it sets the DF bit on all
UDP datagrams that aren't fragmented by
the network driver arm
don't ask me why resolve sessions this
is a droid phone how many hosts uh about
250,000 hosts or so over 200,000 plus so
you get a hell of a question how did you
decide to look into a TV among all the
narrow characteristics what you do
what motivates you to look a nice jobs
basically we've motivated by looking at
problems that we've personally
experienced we've personally experienced
a problem we're in the middle of the
network there was a path MTU hole and
that broke SSH connections from Germany
to exceed but not from Germany to
comcast to XE because it was in the
middle of the network arm as so that's
how we chose that so proxies are another
thing that we see way too many of their
delicate things proxies assume that the
traffic conforms to the protocol but we
control both ends because for everything
but HTTP and DNS we're connecting to a
custom server on our end over a custom
protocol namely you connect and it sends
back the IP and port number so this
allows us all this port filtering policy
if the response is received as expected
we don't detect filtering there could be
a smarter proxy that goes oh this is
just somebody playing games i'm going to
allow it um if the IP address has
changed this says either the the this
protocol is redirected through a
different computer or the user has a
load balancing network connection
between multiple IP addresses or the
user started metalizer closed it and
opened it elsewhere which is why these
days we do tests in order so we'll see
that if the connection fails so if you
get a connection and then no data back
um then the port is blocked somewhere in
the network if the connection fails all
together so the sin fails to connect but
the interesting thing is is the
connection succeeds and different data
is returned it passes through a declared
proxy the proxy actually sent something
back that was unexpected to us um and if
the connection succeeds but no data is
returned oops sorry I then the request
or response was blocked by a network
device that was probably protocol aware
that something in the network does oh
this is a protocol violations stop it
that's actually quite common
so a few surprises pop proxies are
amazingly common seven percent of
sessions reject our protocol violation
another six percent actually send us a
proxy banner and it's almost invariably
localhost antivirus that the localhost
antivirus routine is block mail worms by
intercepting pop connections they don't
actually end up intercepting IMAP SSL or
any of those so it's questionable how
well it works in practice but we see a
lot of it um Nats do ftp proxies for
those who remember networking 101 ftp is
broken in bass ackwards um so the data
connection comes from the server to the
client so most Nats are large number of
Nats just don't bother doing port
forwarding and parsing the protocol they
just run a proxy arm what that there's a
no-good address translation yeah the
home gateways okay for the ass that's
yeah
sorry I capitalize the s oops um cipa
where devices are amazingly common this
local antivirus programs
finally I'll do
we don't have screen capture we have the
banner that it returns and often the
banner says avg pop proxy so the data
coming back is specifically saying what
the product is um sip aware network
devices are surprisingly common on this
is a big headache for those doing VoIP
work um we saw less SMTP filtering than
we expected only about twenty-five
percent blocked SMTP requests to our
server and eight percent rejected the
protocol violation which basically
suggests that many isps are doing port
25 filtering dynamically they're looking
at the network if you have a little port
25 they allow it if you have too much
then you're blocked um this is a
compromise this keeps the spam box from
spamming but keeps the support calls
down expected results port port 443 is
almost completely unmolested run an ssh
server on port 443 back at your home
institution you will thank yourself when
you're on oddball networks and the
windows port blocking is very common um
and this was distressing port UDP port
1434 the slammer worm of what eight
years ago that single UDP port which is
in the ephemeral range so you can have
stuff randomly assigned to use that port
twenty thirty percent of the net still
blocks it it's kind of distressingly hi
um DNS is commonly firewalled
ninety-nine percent have dns access that
is they can seem to contact our server
but of those ten percent failed to fetch
non DNS over port 53 which says there is
some device in the network path that's
going oh this doesn't look like DNS kill
it which means you better hope that as
you deploy DNS SEC that this device
actually understands the NS enough to
not kill your legitimate DNS traffic um
DNS is somewhat proxy one-point-four
percent have the DNS request that is
sent from the client direct to a remote
machine redirected through some other
system um in this case I've seen Nats
where if you don't set the recursive
desired bit it will actually even block
those connections um DNS filtering on
the wire you sit see that ten percent
number a lot of these devices we've
already shown don't actually understand
the DNS protocol quad a records get
blocked text records get blocked unknown
resource records get blocked ed and s
gets blocked oh you wanted to use DNS
SEC to validate certificates so you
don't have to deal with didja note our
part 2 sorry you are out of luck the
network has decreed DNS X shall not work
for 12 percent of users this is actually
a big problem for those who want to do
DNS SEC to reduce a lot of the
certificate problems HTTP proxies um
well we took advantage of the custom
HTTP server so known headers random
capitalization on any proxy that
resynthesizer headers will change
capitalization so if you see the
capitalization of the connection header
changed that may be a sensor web proxy
at least one vendor changes just that
headers capitalization um HTTP proxies
might not handle unknown requests they
may have a bug that's now 23 years old
at this field where it follows the host
field um about 5% plus show evidence of
some HTTP proxy so it's significant we
also detect caches because the hidden
cache much cash so basically by having a
custom web server we can lie about the
cache control headers and so the first
time you fetch an image it shows up like
this the second time you fetch the image
it shows up like this same size
different md5 arm no
sighs four percent of IP show in path
HTTP caching which be all fine and good
but fifty percent of the caches are
broken fifty percent of the cash is cash
serve cache data that the server says oh
cash any cash that may exist in the
network don't cash this please they cash
it anyway um hidden filtering must
filter about ten percent of hosts have
virus filters that are running on the
end hosts itself we test with the icar
test virus structure using for don't
cash or using all of them i we we do
weekly of kindly sir don't cash and
strongly which is everything that says
don't cash this thing that is even with
the strong one a lot of this is with
week a lot of this with weekly
uncatchable will still cash but we do
see a fair number where strongly
uncatchable will still cash like during
development we had problems where the
NSF network would change connection from
clothes to keep alive and we weren't
handling that and it would cash things
that were explicitly marked as oh my god
do not cash these are usually uh I
species in foreign countries where
bandwidth costs more or corporate
networks yeah it's a similar question so
basically we have a full percent of
eyepiece then it's about like more than
10,000 eyed peas
so now did you try to look into the
cities we haven't looked into
geographical beyond just sort of country
level that that certain countries are
much more prevalent than others so like
New Zealand you see a lot of web caches
so what would be a hump it will be a few
ice peace lies I it's very very rare
among us ISPs it is much more common
among foreign is PSP where they have
high transit costs
I'm desired fashion I but if the client
sends whatever they reload these modify
sins assume that they are there that and
then imagine we don't check for that but
I would not bet on it since they were
cashing stuff that were marked from the
server as oh my god do not cash so that
the browser itself should always be
generating new requests another problem
we see is big buffers um they're all
over the place they're in access devices
they're in network drivers there in
wireless access cards basically
everywhere there's a buffer there's odds
are somebody involved in building it
thought bigger was better ah and so what
we do is we just do it UDP hammer we do
a max rate UDP flow see how much the
latency increases then go the other way
and see what what happens the other way
and it's just an endemic problem so this
is uh the what we call the graph of pain
basically it's the upload bandwidth and
the inferred buffer capacity based on
the delay and packet size and we get
nice vertical striations suggesting that
we're getting realistic measurements of
buffers we get nice horizontal
striations that indicate common service
tears anything right of the green line
under stress the user experiences a half
second of latency anything right of this
red line under stress you can induce two
seconds of latency into the users
connection okay I'm a full rate TCP flow
I fill up the full buffer and I'll
alternate between full and half bill and
the saw to thing if the buffer is a
simple dropped tail queue and I have
some latency sensitive thing like a sin
that sin now sees that full buffer delay
as the packet goes through and basically
the net can't walk and chew gum
yes because a lot of these are either in
the wireless card or in the access
device the cable modem and dsl modem
hardware arm and this is a downlink is
fairly bad uplink is worse and it
basically is until you do a full rate
transfer at the bottleneck there's no
problem once you do everything
interactive goes to heck this is why if
you have roommates don't allow them to
run BitTorrent your gaming will suffer
even if we just do users self-reporting
as wired connections to exclude the
wireless buffers which are unfortunately
big um we still see a lot of systems
with very large buffers so we're able to
fill up buffers and if we can fill them
up a TCP flow can and if it's just a
drop tail q they're in trouble um we
have this lovely graph of just comcast
users um god bless biases in your data
set well we only really see two big
bands of capacity which is what you'd
expect they're more homogeneous they
have a lot of rental cable modems and
there's at least some suggestion that
some cable modems actually implemented
buffering properly that is in a simple
drop tail Q you put a max delay not a
max capacity and you do that and you get
good behavior um it's great if you're
doing just dumb drop tail Hugh's it gets
you ninety percent there with just a
comparator and a timestamp arm however
we track down these cable modems it
looked like one old linksys I bought one
of these off of fleabay plugged it in
and got the comcast walled garden saying
this cable modem is too old to connect
to our network which suggests that at
least one hardware vendor used to get it
right and then doesn't anymore
but basically it's the walk and chew gum
problem um there's some work for ninety
percent solutions smarter Nats I hate
Nats but if you're going to have them
anyway it you can have them do queue
management arm so that you can fix your
network with a better NAT arm the
hundred percent solution is very hard
basically every buffer which might be
congested need smart queue management um
and this is required if you want sub
hundred millisecond latency under load
so if you want clean VoIP when you're
doing full bit torrents you need smart
queues and X domain wild carding is an
endemic at this point this is the
problem where you do a typo and you get
to a helpful search page from your isp
strangely enough this helpful search
page is filled with ads um when they do
wildcard they're often broken seriously
they don't just wild card dub-dub-dub
which the browser generates they'll
wildcard anything so they basically
assume that every DNS lookup is only
from a web browser because the only
thing they return is the address of a
web server six percent most of these
being open dns but some not open dns
wild card sir fail um so uh they don't
care to limit collateral damage um one
percent of the non opendns sessions five
percent overall will wild card in a
record for a zero answer reply so if i
have an ipv6 test site it returns a quad
a record and queries for the a record
return a valid answer with a zero number
of answers so it's basically the server
is saying this name is valid there's
just no record for it OpenDNS wildcards
up a a record you cannot build an ipv6
test site and expect it to work reliably
if you have open open d
NS clients um this is a bug i reported
it to a months ago as far as i know this
bug is still there if you're going to
use third-party dms use google public
dns it doesn't have these issues and
this is disturbing we actually track
down the vendor literature this is for
one to three dollars per customer per
year that for what for even a big isp is
slightly more than pocket-lint they will
drastically change how the internet
operates but this is the interesting one
and this it directly affects this
company some ISPs were manipulating dns
results for Google Yahoo and Bing this
is what I showed at the start Yahoo and
Bing lookups always return the IP
address of a third-party controlled
proxy in one of two address ranges
google was sometimes faithful sometimes
an ISP controlled proxy sometimes a
third-party proxy and the behavior was
set / isp so the ISPs had specific
control over how Google was manipulated
Google put a halt to all Google proxying
back in May by throwing up a CAPTCHA on
the search page with a linker with a
link to a page of why did I get this
CAPTCHA your ISP is doing this stuff
without your permission presumably they
also called their lawyers involved um
depending on most lawyers you talk to
call this wiretapping um and the records
are for clear proxy this isn't Akamai
notes so we when Yahoo and Bing don't
have clean reverse we now do a direct
probe of the server because a lot of
them Akamai you don't get clean reverse
DNS on um but these are not Akamai notes
these are proxies proxy traffic appears
to be unmolested arm as we will see in a
sec it's not the case
um HTTPS proxy is proxy to Google
unmolested because Google is the only
one that runs HTTPS services on any of
these domains so if you are set to one
of these rogue DNS resolvers and go to
https WMU get a complaint from your web
browser going this certificates only for
google arm the non proxied hosts return
a redirect to 255 255 255 255 so that we
can see that it's proxying all three of
these and the banner reveals that it's
squid proxy invalid request put up a
page referring to fishing dash warning
sitecom which is a godaddy parked domain
with anonymous registration and would be
a dead end except that if you google for
fishing dash warning dash sitecom you
get complaints about google being down
because if the proxy has an internal
error it also throws up this banner so
when the proxy breaks the user thinks
Google is down sees this banner and if
you search for it you get this so
anybody who has friends on the dns
library side at microsoft client-side
DNS SEC validation is a must-have we
cannot trust the recursive resolver um
so why were they doing this well mmm
these ISPs had this behavior as of this
summer Cavalera cogent direct pc
frontier fuse ibbs insight broadband
megapath paetec rcn wide open west and
EXO who here uses frontier double check
your network or use a third-party DNS
resolver
because when the we do these lookups on
the client ship them to the server and
record them and we saw that the ious
these ISPs were routing the user
requests for Yahoo and Bing through
these proxies clients from yes dozens to
hundreds depending on the ISP and the
only experience problem almost all of
them it depends on the ISP so like
paetec only one of their resolver
clusters use this and other ones did not
a frontier pretty much all their
resolver clusters did this um um
actually weighed on I'd like to talk to
you later we'd like to do some testing
with frontier um mine our yeah right
here online our your home network using
frontier okay so charter was doing this
but they stopped and Iowa telecom was
doing this but when they got bought by
windstream they stopped um who was
responsible this lovely company called
Paks fire who specializes in monetizing
dns um we found packs fires
demonstration servers and a bunch of
other evidence we also found
collaborating data online and this was
the one that stumped us until just a
little over a month ago is why we
couldn't get the proxies to change um
note that also there's an MSR paper that
also noticed this but as far as i can
tell didn't answer the why question
either let alone get the publicity it
turns out there was a the google post
had a pointer to another blog post that
had a URL that was changed and that
allowed us to determine the condition if
the query was from the browser search or
URL bar only and the query matched one
of at least a hundred and sixty five
specific keywords then replaced search
results with a 302 redirect through an
affiliate network it was from the
browser server URL i will get to that
because this is what happened let's say
the search is for CA they're interested
in the state of california
standard flow goes to the resolver the
DNS appliance lies and goes to the proxy
now the proxy actually observes two
things here the first thing it observe
is that it's for a keyword search and
the second is the URL actually does say
this is from the browser URL or search
bar not from the Bing homepage so it
looks for both of these conditions does
a 302 redirect in this case two packs
fires own analysis server that goes oh
this is for a specific affiliate program
which goes and does a 302 redirect
through the affiliate program which then
goes and does a 302 redirect back to the
final merchant and after the final
merchant gets the request well in this
case the user ended up at the computer
associates Web Store in the process
presumably the merchant pays the
affiliate program which pays packs fire
which splits the money with the ISP um
this sounds like very complicated but
let's see basically real time well
bounces back and forth and the page
renders and how our users supposed to
know about this um these queries what we
did is we took the Alexa top ten
thousand we stripped out the suffix so
it was just the domain name so like
Google Yahoo Amazon ec2 and we bombarded
this server with queries to see which
one's it would modify this is very soon
they sued you for modifying their
network traffic uh no they've sued us
for libel because we pointed out that
they are they've sued another party for
libel because we pointed out that this
can monitor user search they don't claim
to monitor user search just modify it so
it's okay how long does it take her to
run
this from Angela ha NAT Eliza takes
about 3-4 minutes we do a lot of tests
so arm they they do modify and monitor
but they claim not to record and profile
so from their point of view it's okay
the user clearly notices how because you
get accurate results brother how many
users would actually notice this way Don
do you use a pax fire or to use
frontiers tienes razón a g2 just so you
know to ya me i assume he's watching
some working yeah and i never observed
anything bad i searched me out always
got being basically i feel friendly here
do you yes search bar yes i do what do
you hit the keywords no no like a IE not
gonna have such price Oh in the address
bar you gather idealistic stuff your
arms above the finish let's be finished
what I want to say is basically I know
frontier is doing what we were saying if
i type of address is wrong it's not
resolved to crack yeah that would be
direct data to their own searching yeah
that's their anniversaries 10 actually
talk to us that opt out is pro if
frontier does not add a new opt out the
opt-out they provide on the bottom of
the page is fictional it just sets a
browser cookie so the next time you go
to the page it sends up a fake browser
error message um we have a protocol for
testing their opt out so let's
communicate afterwards so on the 26 we
measured the monetization web of the
things they'd manipulate some were
redirected direct to amazon if you did
amazon ebay paypal it went direct
because they have direct affiliate
programs i got to see before i got tired
of copying company logos alibris
computer associates compusa dinodirect
they went to through linkshare arm
Google Affiliate Network went through a
lot two of which are of note if you type
in HBO or FISA into your address bar on
the 26th you would get to a page saying
uh this double click URL is wrong so you
wouldn't even get to the final
destination um some went through asked
all of these um ended up going to yp.com
with a banner in the top did you really
mean the site you were looking for or
yp.com and a random yellowpages.com
listing in it coles was especially
amusing on the 26th um you would get a
kohls web page framed with an ad for
jcpenney a lot went through Commission
Junction they're the biggest I gave up
at a and some Commission Junction was
then redirected to double-click for
these airlines during this process it's
unclear whether anybody understood how
packs fire was driving the traffic so
these people presumably because that's
how it works then it looks like that
someone went to a search site of
tunneling
yeah or a affiliate at so an ad on
somebody's webpage so um us man uh all
three big affiliate programs linkshare
google + commission junction suspended
the accounts within two business days
they didn't know as far as we know so
the current situation they halted the
proxy server redirection to affiliate
links within 24 hours of public
disclosure um but they've as of the 16th
maintained the DNS redirections that our
routing user traffic through the proxy
servers so they can resume modifying
results at a later date presumably um
why they haven't stopped I don't know um
Commission Junction linkshare and Google
have all publicly suspended packs fires
account pending further investigation um
we haven't heard anything more from them
but they've all publicly stated the
account is at least temporarily
suspended um and so that's amazing what
is PS will do to manipulate traffic like
we now see at least two eyes fees that
do in path for a for rewriting where
they have an IDs box that looks at HTTP
replies and if the HTTP reply is a 404
they inject a JavaScript redirect to
their advertisement page that's a
different company that's too
so it felt like the ESPYs are the
problems both um there are ISPs that use
packs fire for annex domain wild carding
that don't do this behavior um it's both
um that's what they sell to the ISP but
their direct participants in the traffic
they're the ones running the proxy
servers so they are the ones that are
providing the infrastructure and running
the systems that are monitoring user
search requests and modifying the
results or at least were monitoring and
modifying so conclusions well this
worked we actually did right once one
run anywhere and actually got it to work
you can as a small group build a robust
and comprehensive network measurement
and diagnostic tool we got slashed out
it in sisseton and never noticed with a
tool that does full rate UDP flows for
10 second bursts um we didn't get
noticed um we did a lot of sneakiness
because well the network is your
adversary these days oops so we we
viewed the network as an adversary and
tried to trip it up and we found
interesting things listen do the longer
term monitoring stretch it seems like
things like slashed up you're only gonna
show up one session at once it plays a
lot of users use it for debugging now so
it's become something that people run on
a regular basis were 20 to 70 sessions
an hour just at random baseline at this
point because of random links people
running it people getting to starbucks
and running it etc etc um
us a fair number of network
administrators really like the tool
because it allows them to help debug
their own and their parents networks
debugging debugging performance
connection no connection problems like
NAT issues but what if online connection
doesn't work not connect to a sobre how
can I hope it does because there are a
lot of problems where the connections
sort of works so for example the
internet seems slow what causes me yeah
um or some sites aren't loading right
that could be a dns error so like for
example OpenDNS by wild carding sir fail
if the site's DNS server is down you'll
get oddball opendns stuff rather than
the legitimate response um so so there's
a lot of things like that there's a lot
of just weird edge cases um one of the
tests we do is background outages so the
test takes three minutes during that
three minutes we look for we do one ping
every tenth of a second if we lose three
packets in a row we alert that so that
says your network is flaky and dropping
you also get the chip our work with
Charlie rise in can you put them
together somehow I mean that we actually
do use the tripwire test to see if we're
in a frame and we do direct HTTP request
to see if some replies are modified so
we do do similar detection so we include
tripwire functionality in this oops
so in that work you discover bunch of
ISPs injecting content into yet the
result page yeah and we see two isps
injecting content into 404 pages which
is something that you actually really
not be able to do with the tripwire um
because it's really kind of because of
how the framing and stuff like that
works in the redirections so there's a
lot of that stuff
so for ipv6 it seems like there's a lot
of negative lessons here then there's a
lot of things that will break is there
anything we can take as a positive like
here's a way in which we could deploy
ipv6 oh I maybe six is actually looking
remarkably good in our data we about 5%
of the users have ipv6 connectivity the
gross problem of broken ipv6 means
broken internet to dual stack sites is
no longer the case that that apple and
opera fix those showstoppers so now
they're basically everybody's doing
happy eyeballs so that um if you get a
quad a record nna record you try them
both if whichever one finishes first is
the one you use ipv6 path MTU discovery
is much less broken than v4 mostly
because most ipv6 is going through
tunnels but at the same time it has that
minimum 1280 x 10 to you that's that's
enforced in the spec so the path MTU and
fragment issues for v6 seem to be a lot
better one of the things that's nice for
v6 is it gets the Nats out of the way
because the Nats just just pass traffic
so it reduces the fragment problems um
so um port filtering on v6 is vastly
less than V for a lot of computers have
v6 without knowing it because if Torito
and 624 arm the situation with 624 is
now vastly better than it was a year ago
where 624 turned on would mean your
computer broke for dual stack sites now
it just means if six divorce turned on
and it doesn't work it doesn't work and
it doesn't matter for those those are
deployed in the network infrastructure
so how 624 works is your V for packet
you incur your v6 half that you
encapsulated in v4 to a special anycast
address it gets to the first one strips
it out since the v6 on and then the v6
has your v4 address embedded in it
but goes to a special v6 anycast address
gets to a proxy that re encapsulate sand
sends it on our own
very few ISPs are six to four is
actually something that's just on the
client torito's just on the client and
Microsoft has it on windows and it
actually works most of the time now um
the so the the v6 story is it's still
pretty rare on the order of five percent
but it's not breaking things which means
turning on v6 is no longer the
catastrophe it was a year ago and some
retail ISPs are shifting to it so like
Comcast is supporting v6 and trial
deployments as native v6 to clients I
think mostly because they want to use
dual stack light to handle the v4
address space exhaustion problem so
there's a half an hour break I'm sorry
more question I have a half an hour
break the best sausage